[Music]
i'm laura jones in new york tonight
democrats chances of holding on to power
looking more and more bleak as a record
number of immigrants flood through our
southern border the biden administration
is still trying to convince us that they
have this under control on thursday dhs
secretary mayorkas acknowledged the
surge but defended the administration
handling of it watch
we meet challenges we meet difficult
ones we do so with our heroic workforce
expertise
our plans
and our execution of our plans
here again
just as we did with the challenge of
unaccompanied children
in march of this year
we have a plan
we are executing up our plan
and that takes time
so that's what the secretary said in
public the fox news has obtained leaked
audio of what the secretary is saying in
private and it paints a drastically
different picture watch
a couple days ago i was down in mexico
and i said look
uh you know if uh if our board is the
first line of defense we're going to
lose and this is unsustainable
we can't continue like this
our people in the field can't continue
and our system isn't built for it
okay so he said we're going to lose this
is not sustainable he was talking about
the border but those words could be
easily applied to every facet of the
biden administration
crime is skyrocketing sore gas prices
and inflation u.s officials in
afghanistan are scrambling to leave as
the taliban takes back the country and
lightning speed you could call the
administration a comedy of errors but
nobody's really laughing
it would be great if the bite
administration would just be up front
with us admit that they're failing we're
not as dumb as they think we are
americans can see through their excuses
for the multiple crises that joe biden
has brought upon our country a fox news
post shows most americans disapprove
about his performance on the economy
crime and immigration and if biden
doesn't turn things around soon
he won't be just losing the border he'll
be losing the country too joining me now
stephen miller who's following a lawsuit
against the dhs today he's the founder
of america first legal and lara logan
host of laura logan has no agenda on fox
nation uh laura i want to go to you
first and stephen i'm going to get to
you on the politics but laura i want you
to take me to the border tell me about
the numbers what's the current state
you've done a lot of reporting there
what are you hearing on the ground
well what i'm hearing from everyone
who's on the ground is that they're
breaking records every single day in uh
two shifts in one station on the border
in star county it's called rio grande
city they had eleven 1107
people come across from midnight until 4
p.m the next day that was just one group
over two shifts lawrence and they've
never seen anything like this i mean
literally you have everybody from law
enforcement to border agencies to
federal agencies saying that these are
numbers they have never seen in their
entire careers spanning 10 20 30 40
years but one thing that i think is
really important for people to
understand is that all this does is
define the border over and over and over
again in terms of you know human
migration and the human humanitarian
aspect of this it leaves national
security and border security out of the
equation and that is exactly what the
biden administration wants because the
buy administration can change all of
this literally like that with the snap
of their fingers they change the
policies and they can stop the flow so
what you know from that is that they are
they're not defining the national
security threat they're not countering
the national security threat and they're
not being honest about the national
security threat so what does that tell
you i mean this uh what they're doing is
by design this isn't a result of no
action this is a result of the actions
that they took so it's the outcome they
plan for it's the outcome they've
implemented and it's the outcome that
they're sustaining and so the real
question is how does this benefit the
biden administration because they've
obviously made a calculation that it
does
yeah because they ran on this the media
then pushed back uh he got elected on
this and now they're starting to drop in
the polls so i got to ask you this
stephen miller
do they pivot because we see the only
time that the biden administrator starts
to have some type of pivot is when the
polling comes in and they start to drop
tragically i don't think they're going
to change course on the border and the
reason for that is because
the left is playing the long game on
illegal immigration
their view is that adding millions of
illegal migrants to the country is going
to push the politics of this country
further left and so for the sake of that
goal they are willing to drop in the
polls to pay a price this has been and
remains their highest priority look for
example at the budget reconciliation
bill that they are planning on passing
the 3.5 trillion one we've heard so much
about they're planning on including
amnesty in there that means citizenship
and voting rights for who illegal
immigrants so republicans are going to
have to make the case
to midterm voters
that the democratic party is putting the
safety and security of you your family
and the whole country in grave danger
i'll make one point on this that i think
is very important as bad as the
situation is in afghanistan the
deadliest foreign policy failure by far
of this administration
is the crisis on our southern border the
drugs gangs and crime will claim
thousands of lives in america this year
yeah it's so true and people are dying
as a result of those deadly drugs coming
across because synthetic drugs uh it's
going to kill people laura uh i've
talked to some of my sources on the
ground from when i was on the border the
morale is low what are you hearing from
those border agents i hear some are just
walking off the job they can't take it
anymore
well the border agents have never seen
anything like this and you know
obviously they're completely and utterly
overwhelmed but they know because the
planning started very early on last year
after the election so they know that
this was put into place deliberately and
what you know what they're starting to
ask now is questions like how does you
know the failure of the u.s immigration
system and the failure of the southern
border how does that benefit the byte
administration in terms of a broader
strategy and stephen is right about
playing the long game it's the same
thing when it comes to defunding the
police and you know sadly it's the same
thing when it comes to the fentanyl
which is over 9 000 pounds this year
already in this fiscal year and it's not
even done and you know last fiscal year
was a record and it was only 4 700
pounds so you know you're talking about
exponentially increasing what is a
national security threat it costs this
country billions of dollars because uh
when you have whole communities that are
overdosing and that are addicted then
they're not paying taxes they're not uh
going to work they're not joining the
military they're not staying in school
their their children are not growing up
in stable homes and there's all these
knock-on effects and let's not forget
that the mexican cartels are doing this
exactly you know with an open border
that is that is they are the number one
beneficiaries of the biden
administration's open border and they
are also in a strategic partnership with
the chinese so you know the biden
administration they know perfectly well
what's going on here and if they wanted
to change it they would and they could
the other part of this lawrence is that
why are they moving children from the
border why are they moving them in the
middle of the night why are they moving
them in the under the cover of darkness
and and if you look at the cities where
they're going and you actually overlay
that with covert cases and where there
are spikes in covet cases you know there
are a number of people that are working
on this that i have spoken to who say
that there is significant correlation so
you're exporting covert all over the
country under cover of darkness in order
to change the demographics of this
country and let's not forget the last
point look at all the media headlines
about the census over the last few days
you know which were all about oh
america's white population is down the
census confirms it the future of america
is diverse yeah it sure is you know that
when you're uh making sure that it's as
diverse as you want it to be yeah
i'm just wondering where all the elected
officials that were crying at the border
about the kid's safety i mean they're
packing these kids and parents and
they're like sardines and no one says
anything about it within the democratic
party no aoc no squad no nancy pelosi i
don't even know what kamala harris is i
mean they keep giving her job after job
and she does absolutely nothing if
republicans get back in power and do
nothing they don't deserve your vote
thank you too so much hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else